みんなたくさんのコメントありがとう僕は今までたくさんのペア具を召喚してきた
また今回もツイッターのリプでたくさんのリップが僕の元に届いたさ
だから今日も新発売の便は紹介するよみんな俺について来な
はいラング奴は脳じゃ楽家[ __ ]はあ g
いっ
[音楽]
まず注目すべきところはこのパッケージ日あるなぁから子が書いてある
ねえ
もうやめましょうこういうの編集が疲れるもっとシンプルにいきましょう
だから5歳てやって
すっごいリプきたんですよ twitter ねー
なんかもスペアが出るたびになんか
もうてあげる的な
キャーなんでしょうね嬉しいことですというなんか
あ
認識されるって本当に
[音楽]
申し上げましょう
ああ
同年校田中を表現するかが見どころだと思いますよ
おっ基礎油断していたあっという間に10分経っちゃった
よく焼けちゃったよ中国はですね
この欲求焼きそばソースがどんな色でどういう色になるかが
ん
実は
楽しみんたら止まってるんですよねグッ
一応者ぶりたい
ああっあんまりたら僕じゃないんです
[音楽]
こんな感じです
さあ食べてみましょう果たして論 nars になってるのでしょ
編集疲れるんですよ公営活動ねー
変数疲れるんです
[音楽]
鼻詰まってて匂いが分かります何か美味しい気がする
うーん
場所によるななんかソースが合うソースの量が少ないからだ
すっごいたらこうなところとソフトねーみたいな味の床があります
これは混ぜる人のここが試されます
フェアングって基本的に麺が美味しいかなぁ
ここらへんの商品はハズレがないと
思っても過言ではないでしょ今日のフィルミスですぜひそこのタラコ唇-1
カルト信者の人みんなみんな
美味しいんで食べてみてください
店
[音楽]